Forrest Gump was a big-time
crowd-pleaser and a sequel would have
definitely also earned stacks of cash at
the box office
so what kept a potential part 2 from
ever hitting theaters well stop eating a
shrimp and grab your running shoes as we
find out why Forrest Gump - never got
made
Once Upon a Time Tom Hanks was best
known as a comedian but then the
oscar-winning double whammy of
Philadelphia and Forrest Gump turned him
into an esteemed actor and gave him
serious Hollywood clout following those
back-to-back lead actor wins Hank's
could have easily made a Gump sequel but
instead he opted for Apollo 13 so why
didn't he revisit his iconic character
in 1995 Hanks said that he didn't think
Forrest Gump - was a good idea for one
thing is he told Entertainment Weekly he
was tired of all those catchphrases but
more importantly he was worried a sequel
would hurt the legacy of the original
film as he put it I have to confess I
don't see this as a franchise a sequel
would ruin what we had done it would be
like jaws - while Forrest Scott might
seem like a distinctly cinematic
experience the movie was actually based
on a novel by Winston groom so when it
came time to adapt the story for the big
screen
paramount tapped Eric Roth to write the
screenplay Ross is an incredibly
respected writer who won an Academy
Award for his Gump script and went on to
nab even more Oscar nominations for the
likes of The Curious Case of Benjamin
Button and a star is born and as it
turns out in between writing all these
acclaimed screenplays Roth was busy
hammering out a script for a Forrest
Gump sequel for a brief moment it looked
like we might return to the world of
Lieutenant Dan and the Bubba Gump shrimp
company but while Roth is a fantastic
writer who's produced some spectacular
movies his Forrest Gump - script might
not be his most mainstream work Forrest
Gump is a movie that wants you to cry
and the saddest scene in the entire film
is probably when Jenny dies leaving
Forrest absolutely wrecked played by
Robin Wright jenny has lived a pretty
rough life and she eventually contracts
a mysterious virus that doctors can't
cure it is implied that she succumbed to
AIDS and that was going to play a big
role in the aborted sequel according to
Eric Roth Gump and his son now lived in
Florida and everyone in his community
was going to freak out when they learned
Forrest
Jr
contracted AIDS from his mom as Roth
noted to consequence of sound we had a
funny sequence where they were
desegregating busing in Florida at the
same time so people were angry about
either the busing for their kids having
to go to school with the kid who had
AIDS so there was a big conflict so
according to Roth Forrest Gump who was
going to use racism and the AIDS crisis
together for the sake of a comedy bit
those are two highly sensitive topics
that most movie goers would probably
agree aren't the best fodder for humor
in addition to the phenomenal acting and
nostalgic soundtrack Forrest Gump is
also praised for its visual effects the
folks at Industrial Light and Magic
actually won an Oscar for their
incredible work perhaps the most
impressive accomplishment was putting
Tom Hanks into archival footage
alongside famous historical figures like
Richard Nixon and John F Kennedy Eric
Roth planned on having Forrest encounter
even more famous figures in the sequel
including an iconic cameo that doesn't
sound like a great fit evidently Forrest
was going to be very involved in the
saga of OJ Simpson somehow he would be
the one responsible for tossing the
bloody glove found at Simpsons Brentwood
home stranger still Forrest would
somehow wind up in the back of Simpson's
white Bronco as the football star leads
the police on the slowest car chase in
history the OJ Simpson trial was
obviously a huge news story in the 90s
but it would probably feel bizarrely out
of place in a Forrest Gump sequel for
all its happy moments Forrest Gump is
ultimately a tragedy after all it ends
just moments after Forrest gives a
tearful goodbye at Jenny's grave as for
the sequel Eric Roth had no intention of
giving our chocolate loving hero a happy
ending speaking with Yahoo Roth
explained that Forrest would have a new
love interest a Native American woman he
meets while riding a bus she was going
to be a nursery school teacher and every
day Forrest would sit on a park bench
and share a lunch break with her but she
wouldn't be teaching at any old nursery
school instead it would be located
inside the Federal Building in Oklahoma
City where in 1995 Timothy McVeigh set
off a truck full of explosives Forrest
girlfriend was going to die in the blast
worse still it would happen while
Forrest was sitting on that bench as the
building explodes right behind him which
sounds more than a little
so if Eric Roth had a script ready to go
how come Forrest Gump tune never got
made it turns out that he turned in his
final draft on September 10th 2001 the
very next day the world was turned
upside down the 9/11 terrorist attacks
impacted the production of quite a few
films and it stopped the Gump sequel
from even getting past the screenplay
face after all the movie was supposed to
end with Forrest girlfriend dying in one
of the most devastating terrorist
attacks in American history and that
just wasn't going to fly in the
aftermath of 9/11 so on the day of the
attacks he met up with Tom Hanks and
director Robert Zemeckis to commiserate
we looked at each other and said this
movie has no meaning anymore in that
sense so it's probably for the best that
Forrest Gump who never happened from
what we know of the screenplay
it doesn't sound like it would have been
anywhere near as beloved as the original
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]